قال المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان ان
الانفجار الذي وقع في دير الزور اليوم
استهدف مبنى للفسايا الايرانيه ما اسفر عن
مقتل اربعه اشخاص واضاف مدير المرصد
العربي على الاستهداف تزامن مع تحليق
طائرات مسيره بالمنطقه وتسبب ايضا في
اصابه ثمانيه عناصر من هذه الفصائل وكان
اعلام النظام السوري افاد في وقت سابق
بمقتل ثلاثه مدنيين واصابه سبعه اخرين في
فجال لغم من مخلفات تنظيم داعش في حي
الحميديه بدير الزور مشاهدينا معنا
وما هي المعطيات او ماذا تقول المعطيات
المتوفيه لكم حول هذا الهجوم خاصه مع
التضارب حول كوني هجوم بطائره مسيره او
بلغم ارضي كما يقول النظام السوري
نعم صباح الخير طبعا مجددا دعنا نقول بان
اللغم الارضي امر يعني محسوم بشكل كامل لا
يوجد شيء اسمه لهم ارضيه يتسبب بهذا
الدمار هائل في تلك المنطقه هذا الامر
محسوم ومنتهي بالنسبه لنا ومؤكد بانه لا
يوجد لهم ارضي دمرت تلك المنطقه وسبب بهذا
المنشار الكبير بالنسبه لاستهداف الطائره
المسيره لمقتل الاسلحه هل هو استهداف من
قبل هذه الطائره المسيره التي ادت لهذا
الانفجار ام هو انفجار من على الارض في
عمليه امنيه استهدفت هذه الميليشيات ولكن
ما جرى من هذا الانفجار فضح موضوع تخزين
السلاح تخزين مصانع الاسلحه ضمن مناطق
مدنيه وهنا نقول للنظام حقيقه الامر الولد
الذي يقتل في تلك المنطقه يعلم بان هذا
المربع هو مربع ايراني ويعلم بان هذه
المشافي والمستوصفات والمنازل يقوم فيها
ما يعرف بحجاج حزب الله او حجاج ايرانيين
الانفجار استهدفا مستودع للايرانيين مصنع
تصنيع صواريخ ما تعرف بصواريخ قصيره المدى
التابعه الايرانيين في هذه البقعه المدنيه
من التراب السوري بانها منطقه مدنيه صرفه
والانفجار تسببها في دمار هائل هذا الطائر
المسيره التي كانت تحلق عند ضفاف الفرات
هي التي استهدفت هذا المبنى الى الان لم
استطيع التاكيد او النفي ولكن الامر مرتبط
ببعضه هل هناك كانت تراقب عمليه ان الامر
سيتم والانفجار سيتم في تلك المنطقه
الانفجار مثل ما شاهدنا قوى انفجار شديد
هو بشكل قطعي ليس انفجار رغب بشكل نهائي
اذا لم يكن هذا الانفجار ناجم عنهم كما
يقول النظام ما الذي يدفع النظام السوري
لتبني هذه الروايه في تقديرك يا اخي يا
سيد نظام اخر من يعلم في تلك المناطق ماذا
يدور يعني حقيقه الامر النظام لا يعلم بان
هنا قد يكون النظام ذات ذاته لا يعلم بان
هناك قيادي من حزب الله يخطل في هذه
الفيلا او تلك في الاراضي السوريه يعلم
بان تلك المنطقه للاصدقاء الاصدقاء يعني
حلفاء النظام السوري ولكن لا يعلم يمنع
عليه ان يعلم ماذا يدور في تلك المنطقه
لان الايرانيين وحزب الله في كثير من
الحالات لا يفيقون بالنظام السوري والذين
يتعاملون مع النظام السوري ويخشونه ان
يكونوا عملاء لاسرائيل او الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اذا كانوا نظام
الميليشيات ايضا يستغلون هذه المناطق
المدنيه لتخزين الاسلحه كما تفضلت هل يشمل
ذلك ايضا المستشفى الايراني هل كان هدفا
لهذا الانفجار او هذا الهجوم يعني
هو المشفى
الايراني في كفر سوسه منطقه المدرسه
الايرانيه اين المدارس السوريه واين
المشافي السوريه واين ابناء الشعب السوري
ولماذا ايران تصر ان تبقى في داخل التراب
السوري وان سوريا يجب ان تستمر بالتدمير
على التمدد الايراني على حساب ابناء الشعب
السوري الى متى لا نعلم
طيب اخر التحديثات حول الاحصائيات حول
اعداد القتلى والمصابين ايضا بحسب ما توفى
لكم بمعلومات
ما نستطيع تاكيده بان هناك اربع قتله